silence could we get that one more time
oh god damn it I really I feel like I
need the song again I did it myself I
need a song myself against it okay so
here we go for ticks
they actually trucks laughter you seen
the per second part together yeah yeah I
feel like you're like the modern-day
Bach yeah amen no I'm broke
no baroque be beyond the Baroque the
time period is when Bach oh right right
I'm knowledgeable about the peonies yeah
I used to used to watch dirty debutantes
with Ed Powers do you remember that
mm-hmm
he was like a greasy old jewy guy who
had his own little porn series called
dirty deputes
what was it about Debbie no not dirty
Debbie it was a series they did like
hundreds of them and he did it out of
his own house they're pretty quality
work well you're 67 years old so we were
pretty [ __ ] late I'm pretty [ __ ]
old and then I remember going to this
place and I don't know what talking but
that's but least I'm on them on
Lankershim and victory in North
Hollywood my friend yes kids now so I
don't think he's happy about me bringing
this up so there used to be a place
there where you would walk into he told
me to go and you would walk in and you
put quarters in a machine and that a
[ __ ] metal door would slam open and
there was a naked girl there right and
you could just jerk off and there's a
phone a real naked she's danced yeah and
you would you would talk to them and go
hey and you would masturbate those are
some sad [ __ ] days there's a thing
that's that's gone down
no but they used to be a place I feel
like we should bring that back and then
I don't know I feel like that's like a
novelty to jerk off through a glass
contraption while holding a phone my
earlobe would well you're definitely
multitasking yeah is training you to
multitask yeah but like yeah I remember
going to and then I remember like not
having enough coins and it's yeah I'm
about to combat it shut so I'm about to
come and then it's shut and you're like
ah and you're like now coming in a
little a metal box speaking of coming
we've recently had a come revelation
where where you point I didn't hide it I
didn't wait I didn't I didn't tell you
that information for you to say it on
the podcast you absolutely did I get in
but you can tell people what you told
her you had a coming revelation he has
like he has um you know when when liquid
eventually turns to stone okay
[ __ ] Glass Menagerie of nut all by
the side of the bathtub apparently he's
been accumulating for years he has like
crystallized nut glaze it looks like it
looks like cement yeah it looks like
cement because it's like hardened over
the years I hello though it's like
tinted yellow but it's it's layered and
it's against that grey brick already so
it it hides the yellow how do you know
what's the other one is dried because it
might come as a tentacle Oh funny story
so so I was younger I used to masturbate
in only one corner yeah I don't need my
hampers I thought if I move the hamper I
do it in that spot I cover it my parents
will never find the one spot so after
just years in high school that I
obviously move out for college I think
my dad like you know might move my room
it was just a giant circle of like just
dots of yellow that looks like what it's
this so I stopped cleaning my room yeah
as like aa candle wax
oh yeah candle why is a good one
no I've never had a cradle in my room
he's like okay okay so similar thing
your Filipino dad cleaning that corner
well my Filipino mom cleans our tub so
she's been trying to scrub off [ __ ]
nut for four years and she doesn't know
it she's been trying to scrub off his
crystallized nut off of the bathtub
because she's always like darling your
stone is very different here from there
the stone keeps growing stone here it
looks like marble this stone here looks
like dark stone yep I'm so [ __ ] so
bad I feel so bad
[Music]